Film Courage: How often do you work with writers
who are afraid that their ideas will be stolen?
Kaia Alexander, CEO/founder of the Entertainment
Business School/Podcast Host/ Author: Almost every
student I have almost every client I have in my
coaching business has expressed concern about what
have my ideas got stolen and how do I protect my
ideas so a lot of what I teach especially around
week six and week seven of the Entertainment
Business School is how do you protect yourself how
do you go in armed so that you really understand
the language of the business side of the industry
and ultimately of course you cannot copyright an
idea and that's why some production companies will
have you sign something that says hey if we're
going to read your script we can't promise we
don't have another idea like this in development
I was a development exec for a company called
Inferno entertainment and we made films like just
friends with Ryan Reynolds we did the good night
with Gwyneth Paltrow and Penelope Cruz we did a
movie that I help put together called Peaceful
Warrior with Nick Nolte that was based on IP and
all the time we were getting submissions from
managers from producers from agents and we might
have three or four scripts in the read queue that
were about the devil how are you going to protect
an idea okay maybe your Devil is a woman or maybe
your devil is young or old or living on another
cont I mean they're all a different take on the
devil so that's an example of like okay you might
feel like oh my script is so original and it says
take on the devil we've never seen but I'm like
oooh I got four of them here in the read queue
what is undeniable is your voice as a writer
is your your actual work your screenplay your
treatment which you can register with the writer's
Guild which you can also put into the Library of
Congress so those protections to get the writer
Guild protection to get the Library of Congress
protection on your work is huge but you actually
cannot copyright and protect just an idea so you
got to do the work what do you teach students
about IP okay so I love teaching about IP I'm
also a published novelist a lot of experience in
the publishing side of things and as a development
exec I was was looking for IP so when I found
the book Peaceful Warrior that I had loved as a
teen and then went oh I wonder what's happening
with this my boss had said go find us some IP
so I made some phone calls I called the agent I
didn't know you could just call an author's agent
even as a development exact I was like I could
just pick up the phone and call them okay so I
did and the agent's like oh yeah well Nick Nolte
has the rights to Peaceful Warrior oh really oh
okay well let's contact Nick's office so we reach
out hey what's happening with Peaceful Warrior oh
there's a script oh great well we might want to
co-finance that we were doing some co-financing
with new line cinema at the time so they send over
the script we're like this script is pretty good
next thing peaceful Warrior is getting made as
a film so exacts feel more confidence when there
is some Legacy to a project I mean we're seeing
this with huge decisions now like that Jeff Bezos
has made at Amazon to pursue Lord of the Rings it
was like what a $400 million IP acquisition so of
course you're probably not at Jeff Bezos level of
acquiring IP but I even instruct my students pick
up the phone if you have a book that you love what
if the rights are available did know you can call
the agent what so I had a student last session Who
Loved this particular book series that had elves
in it and she's I give anything to adapt this oh
but it's so popular I'm sure it's not available
she's already talking herself out of it I said
pick up the phone and call the agent and let's
find out if the rights are available the rights
were available the agent was excited to talk to
her the author was thrilled she had idea for the
whole series she pitched it to them hey this is
what I would love to do with it could I possibly
have the rights she didn't at the time have the
money to pay for an option which always is more
but she did offer a shopping agreement a paid
shopping and they went for it and now she controls
this IP and she's able to do her own adaptation
and she acts so she's looking for a role for
herself that she gets to write for herself but
now that she controls that IP that becomes a
Honeypot for execs who are like oh wait it's
based on IP this the most powerful statement you
can utter to any buyer I have this project based
on IP based on bestselling IP and a lot of cases
a best-selling work has sold tens of thousands
of copies in a year it doesn't have to be Millions
some of the books on the New York Times bestseller
list have sold 40,000 50,000 copies and maybe
if it was a few years ago the rights might be
available so just to encourage that you have the
ability to to contact book agents reach out to
authors directly I am working on an adaptation of
a memoir called Swell [Swell: A Sailing Surfer's
Voyage of Awakening] I reached out to the author
directly Captain Liz Clark I contacted her on
Instagram hey what's happening with your book is
there any plans for television film adaptation
and she said well I've been waiting for the right
team to come along and the rights are available so
the author was ready to engage with me directly
that is the point when you have a yes that is
the point at which you involve attorneys you find
yourself a great reliable entertainment attorney
hopefully someone who comes from a word of mouth
recommendation where okay there's someone I can
trust to put a contract together because you do
have to have a contract to control the IP that's
something I teach my students in the entertainment
business school because it is a significant it is
a significant advantage in your career to control
some IP why is pitching important I think writers
all fall in love with the craft all fall in love
with the words on the page and the story and their
beloved characters and then you realize oh no
I have to sell this somehow how do I actually
sell my work and that's usually where the the
plane runs out of runway for a lot of writers
oh wait what do I do now and maybe they just go
oh I'm going to write another screenplay next
thing you they got 30 screen plays so you have
to learn pitching so many writers like I don't
want to be in sales I don't have to sell anything
that's why I'm a creative Kaia no I'm so sorry I
have to let that you are in sales you're going
to write things and then you're going to need to
take them out and sell them you're always pitching
so whether you're talking to a producer at a film
festival or you're trying to get representation
you're pitching yourself whether you're querying
or you're reaching out to others in your wolf pack
saying hey do anyone who might be right for me you
need to be able to talk about yourself and your
work confidently because the first experience
that buyers so development execs and producers
people who can actually make your show make your
film have of you is how well do you talk about
your story how well do you talk about your work
and I teach a technique called the stealth pitch
because it's quietly a pitch but it makes it fun
for the exec or the producer to hear and they
go tell me more so I teach that to my writers
in the entertainment business school so that they
feel like okay I have some arrows in my quiver to
know how to talk about myself there are other
wonderful teachers in the industry like Carole
Kirschner who I know you've had on your show who
teach pitching so well and there's formatting
around it that gives you like in a bowling lane
the bumpers and you feel like oh I'm not going to
end up in the gutter yeah you could can just head
straight for the strike how do you talk about your
story the world your personal connection to that
material if you're pitching TV like this season
future Seasons you're letting them know really
essentially what you love about your story so when
I was a development exact probably heard I don't
know hundreds of pitches what I will tell you
is that we never bought or financed a film where
there wasn't passion in the pitch I a lot of half
of the pitch meetings I took the producers and
everybody who was there he got really stiff and
like really nervous okay we're just going to we're
going to tell you about the story and these other
characters and and they look terrified and they
couldn't relax and just banter oh I can't wait to
tell you about my favorite character because she
climbed Mount Everest at a time when no women were
doing that in her flip-flops whatever it happens
to be right here look here's the axe that she the
the ice axe that she used to do it and then the
exact are like oh my gosh you we feel connected
so the passion to can carry you far your energy
your joy Your Love of this story these characters
can carry you really far so you bring the passion
and then you start to learn some of the structure
and then you practice and I will tell my students
always practice practice to yourself in the mirror
then put your phone on a stand and film yourself
talking about your story talking about your work
you film it and then you go grab your spouse grab
your best friend grab somebody you're working with
and say hey would you you got four minutes for me
to just I want to tell you this story and then you
put your phone up and you film yourself pitching
telling someone else the story pitching is a
little bit of like a four-letter word for people
who go oh no it's sales I'm not sales-y and then
they freeze and it gets scary but if you find your
passion and you can communicate it and then tell a
decent story woven in you're already 90% further
down the road than someone who can't clearly
articulate with passion the story that they're
telling.